we are here to talk about what what what
women want oh man what are they forget I
got a couple right I've been listening
to a lot of Drake
so like figure that out women want Ryan
Gosling obviously looks are important
women like attractive guys what's a
good-looking guy you gotta have a great
smile I gotta look cute superficial but
it's superficial but it goes both ways
guys and girls I think women are
attracted to pretty boys what like what
is the definition of a pretty boy though
there's different kinds of pretty boys I
don't like the pretty like I been three
hours in the bathroom
I take two hours let me do that I
necessarily don't think the pretty boys
are good looking at I like the the
rugged look using ABS are important like
six-pack abs with like the V you guys
know what I'm talking about I can do
without the ABS I really can't for us
it's more important to know that you're
going to take care of yourself and your
good physique I had a girl tell me that
she would rather have a guy with a
six-figure check I'm six pack abs case
in point money does matter I think money
is important I mean everybody's
different so there are some women who
like I want a rich guy or someone who
like I don't care at all what money yes
I want to be able to do fun stuff you
should be able to not have to worry I
would say money is important because it
indicates like oh like he's got his
stuff together
if a man is passionate and ambitious and
is going after what he wants that's
attractive ambition is very sexy we look
for independent men that they do their
own thing when they want to do it how
they want to do it and that's attractive
I find that sex I could love what I do
but what if I make jack [ __ ] money doing
it I come from Sweden so we usually do
everything equal and split all their
bills annex your question guys with more
money do you find them more attractive I
don't want to date a guy just because he
has money
I do find guys who have more money more
secure that's a different type of
attraction it becomes hard as a guy like
doesn't have a car and he like sleeps on
someone's couch having a job have your
huge more about work ethic someone that
works hard is going to end up making
money for themselves what ranks higher
me yeah security or good looking um
security money
[Music]
intelligence is definitely one of the
more important qualities that I look for
in a man you gotta be a smart guy the
guy with character character and
personality matters so much personality
is key talent make us laugh confidence
and charming life when it comes to women
confidence is everything yep you could
be a less attractive guy less successful
guy confident man
just knows himself and he owns it women
will pay attention people look at you
differently yeah yeah it's like you just
got that peacocking there is a
difference between confidence and
cockiness I don't know why I feel like
that's so hard to find these days a
being who is emotional and also a man
which you can be those things a guy
who's genuinely wants to know about you
and is like interested in who you are
you kind of got to be a little bit of
math on top of that it can't be too nice
I think women are attracted to [ __ ]
the young ladies and I'm attracted to
now they don't like [ __ ] I don't
know about everyone of them but I know a
lot of them are I hate [ __ ] they're
gone I was a nice guy then I had to work
towards being an [ __ ] and then I
started getting more dates they like bad
boys
I think women do sometimes want a bad
boy behind closed doors I will love a
bad boy I definitely am attracted to bad
boy image we hate it though it's like
you end up getting hurt they want like
the dudes you don't treat them as well
who aren't chasing you know what I mean
I do like a little challenge it can't be
too easy we don't want somebody to be
like yes honey whatever you say honey
you're approachable but also you're kind
of a dick as well you feel like he could
protect you they want Clark Kent in the
streets Superman in the sheets and that
is like fat I believe there's this
misconception for men that they need to
be these like super wealthy super
successful like hyper masculine hot guys
with like abs we were looking for a guy
who has qualities across the board the
balance of everything I think a guy that
is internally confident but doesn't have
to bring it out is what women ultimately
want listen
strong dedicated has a goal and a vision
in mind the honest you don't have to
like have all the money you don't have
to have washboard abs a woman just wants
you to be your authentic self the end of
the day I think when it comes to guys we
just need to listen
more now I agree with that we just want
simple things I do I really do I really
do
[Music]